now you say you're sorry for being so
untrue how mainstream media well you can
cry me a river cry me a river cry me a
river Jim Acosta as confidence in the
mainstream media drops to record lows
president Trump's approval rating hits a
new high of fifty percent five points
higher than Barack Obama's at this point
in his presidency we will analyze why
the media's crocodile tears are not
working then why these midterm elections
2018 are the most honest elections that
we've had in a long time and also why
God isn't a socialist finally the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
all right it just got back in from our
nation's capital had a good time walked
around the gold house you know I got to
visit with ya young America's Foundation
gave a speech there on owning the libs
and how wonderful it is I think you can
probably catch that online yeah it might
be streaming it somewhere and I left I
left my compatriots there in DC we were
like ships passing in the night didn't
get to see one another I don't I don't
know if I'm more tired because I just
got off the airplane and I came here or
because I closed down Shelley's back
room with Allie Stuckey last night if it
was one of those two things I'm not sure
which one but a lot of fun anyway I
really enjoyed seeing ya and you know
we're doing this tour in the fall with
you f go f f/a on campus so if you would
like me to come spread the simple joys
of Cove F a to your campus put in a
request through the Yap web site yeah
org I think there should be a link for
for my tour there and you can just put
in a request and we'll set it up we're
gonna be picking those schools and dates
soon so get that in pretty fast but
there's a lot to get to this was really
fun you know talk about a good news
cycle to be hanging around DC we have
the one and only Jim Acosta if Jim
Acosta did not exist conservatives would
have to create Jim Acosta the future
daily water White House correspondent
Jim Acosta he got into a little heat
because he was at a trump event he was
at a trump rally and some Trump
supporters were echoing him I wonder why
I wonder why they would do that and that
seems so crazy so then Jim Acosta went
on television and started crying those
mainstream media crocodile tears here is
mr. Acosta he's covered countless of
these and has become one of the
president's favorite human punching bags
CNN chief White House correspondent Jim
Acosta jim we've seen your videos and
i've i've been to these events too I've
met with countless Trump supporters even
I was shocked at the level of vitriol
that was aimed your way last night give
us an idea of what it felt like to be in
the middle of it well se I mean honestly
it felt like we weren't in America
anymore I don't know how to put it any
more plainly than that Americans should
not be treating their fellow Americans
in this way but unfortunately what we've
seen and this has been building for some
time since
the campaign I've been I've been talking
about this as an issue since the
campaign when the president during the
campaign referred to us as the dishonest
media the disgusting news media liar
scum and thieves and so on and then he
rolled that right into the Oval Office
and started calling as fake news and the
enemy of the people
he is whipping these crowds up into a
frenzy to the point where they they
really want to come after us and you
know we have these these bike rack like
barriers around the press cage as we
call it to protect us essentially from
people who might take things too far
it's unfortunate because and I try to
calmly talk to a lot of these folks at
the rally last night to say listen hey
you know tell me what you want to talk
about here why are you guys so upset
with us and they would kind of go
through a list of questions most of most
of the questions were about why don't
you guys report positive news about the
president and I said hey you know what
we do that we were reporting on this
positive job numbers in the economy last
Friday and my sense of it se is that the
that these opinions that these folks
have at these rallies they're shaped by
what they see in the primetime hours of
Fox News and what they hear from some
conservative news outlets that just sort
of give them this daily diet of what
they consider to be terrible things that
we do over here at CNN it's very
unfortunate but it's it's it's a pitting
of American against American and
honestly it needs to stop honestly it
needs to stop and I'm Ron Burgundy I'm
Ron Burgundy I'm Jim Acosta Ron Burgundy
you never see him and Will Ferrell in
the same room at the same time do you so
he felt like he wasn't in America
anymore and this is the I actually kind
of like Jim Acosta I very serious
someone asked me if the daily wire could
send a representative to the White House
who would it be say it would have to be
Jim Acosta because there's this sort of
guileless Ness to him you know they
report the most absurd fake news all the
time and buy fake news I mean certain
dishonest lines certain actually
inaccurate stories and then also they
just harp on constant negative nonsense
president Trump has the most negative
press coverage in modern presidential
history despite the fact that his
approval rating in the country is 50%
it's actually quite quite high and
despite the fact that we have a booming
we've got peace abroad that we've got
low unemployment record low joblessness
crime down hate crime down all of these
great statistics that we can take off
but the mainstream media harp on issues
that the American people don't care
about they harp on the Russia
investigation that they harp on these
issues that Americans rank in the bottom
bottom percentages of what they care
about what matters to them what it
should be newsworthy which should be
politically newsworthy but they the
other thing to point out here is you've
got this video of Ron Burgundy Jim
Acosta standing there in the press cage
and you've got all these Trump
supporters just making fun of him you
know because they don't like the
mainstream media the mainstream media
are unpopular because they're liars they
carry water for Democrats their dirty
rotten liars but they're not like
punching him in the face they're not
climbing over the cage to stab him or
something like that
there haven't been political attacks on
journalists in America in recent history
there have been some where there are
personal gripes between people and
certain local journalists that's
happened a handful of times but there
haven't you know there isn't a epidemic
of Trump supporters going out and
physically attacking members of the
mainstream media that doesn't exist
what does exist however is members of
the media and also lefties riling up and
inciting violence against Trump
supporters everybody from media types in
the Democratic Party and on the Left all
the way to elected officials ginning up
attacks on Trump supporters on people
who work for president Trump just look
at a few of these tweets talk about a
dehumanizing from PBS and NPR composer
christopher o'reilly quote calling them
deplorable Xizhi euphemized them may be
better to euthanize get it we shouldn't
euphemized them we shouldn't give them a
little nickname we should kill all of
them you don't see that you don't really
see that with Jim Acosta with Trump
supporters - Jim Acosta we make fun of
Jim Acosta because he's eminently
mockable but you don't see that sort of
let's kill them all let's euthanize them
how about a TV host John Murray says
this scene referring to Jim Acosta's
experience at the Trump rally this scene
looks like a modern day
Ku Klux Klan rally amazing to see that
Donald Trump the man occupying the White
House is so comfortable in this
atmosphere of hateful hostility bigotry
and deplorable language god bless
america
Oh where's the hostility coming from sir
where is that how is this like a Ku Klux
Klan rally because that's the easiest
that's the easiest insult it's the worst
thing you can say about a person to say
that their biggest that they're racists
that they're it's the worst thing you
can say in modern America what's the
evidence what's really funny is in the
clip in that clip of Jim Acosta they're
the the first group of people there was
a prominent group on camera is a big
group that says blacks for Trump so just
like all those old Ku Klux Klan rallies
blacks for the Klan you don't see that a
lot that's not true it's just it's just
an insane slander it's insane liable to
say that about Trump supporters and it
really does gin up hatred because what
you're saying is these Trump supporters
are domestic terrorists and we got to
take care of them obviously this is you
know they're oblivious to their to what
what they're saying themselves how about
willpotter
the the author willpotter you said on
Twitter quote I'm truly ashamed that
this is what America has become replace
the Maggi hats and Trump signs and this
is straight out of any number of
authoritarian regimes where journalists
are killed I feel like a foreign
correspondent my own country okay just
replace the maggots and the Trump signs
and the president and the press and the
country and the era and the location and
the weapons and if you replace
everything then it's like another thing
okay that's fine that makes sense I feel
like what does he say that this is a
like when journalists are killed which
journalists have been killed because of
Trump supporters which ones any no okay
that's what I thought
from author Khaled died Abdi Abdi of
Trump's endless vilification of the
media will almost certainly lead to
vigilante violence against journalists
if Trump succeeds in weakening American
institutions sufficiently he could wage
an heir to one style crackdown on his
media critics and independent
journalists did you know that did you
know that Donald Trump is like the
dictator of Turkey the Islamist dictator
of Turkey I didn't know that I didn't
even know Trump was in Islamist hoody
that guy really can slip through the
cracks
so you know he really pulled the wool
over all of our eyes that that's what
you're seeing from the the supporters of
Jim Acosta the people who believe these
crocodile tears that the supporters of
the mainstream media does any Trump
supporter want there to be violence on
media figures no have you heard one
Trump supporter in the media and elected
office call for violence against the
mainstream media no you can't you can't
you can't show me an example of that and
and there's no epidemic point point to
the epidemic point to the incidence
doesn't exist but have you heard even
elected Democrats calling for violence
against Trump supporters absolutely you
have Maxie and baby take it away
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
your evil did you hear that you're evil
and that's why we've got to go to
Republicans houses so that we can keep
them up and terrorize their families and
swarm them in public go out you know I
think of Mitch McConnell and his wife
when the swarming mob goes up there
starts screaming and Elaine Chad's face
that's what they're asking for that's
what the left is saying they're the ones
turning up the rhetoric it's
unbelievable to see these headlines they
say President Trump won't condemn
rhetoric he won't stop rhetoric against
journalists Sarah Sanders won't stop
rhetoric against journalists what about
Maxine Waters what about Cory Booker
what about all of these major Democrats
what about the people who are actually
swarming physically intimidating
attacking Trump supporters well Jim
Acosta sends out his crocodile tears cry
me a river absolutely ridiculous and and
how else by the way we're talking about
this culture of hatred ginning up hatred
and attacks against our fellow Americans
because these news cycles are almost
parodies of themselves at this point the
New York Times has just hired a new
member of the editorial board Sarah Jang
they just hired Sarah Jeon and all of a
sudden some old tweets are coming to
light but when I'm talking about old
tweets I'm not even saying like James
Gunn you know tweets from 2006 2005 over
10 years ago 13 years ago I'm talking
about tweets from just a couple years
ago a few years ago where this woman
this reporter this journalist who was
hired by the New York Times to be on the
Editorial Board says horrific things
about white people not individual white
people horrific things about white
people as a category here are just some
of the quotes and I'm gonna have to
censor them I'm gonna have to like I'm
gonna be silent for half of all of these
quotes because they're really profane
dumb effing white people marking up the
internet with their
opinions like dogs urinating on fire
hydrants okay I guess that's what I'm
doing right now I'm just marking up the
internet with my opinions sorry another
one are white people genetically
predisposed to burn faster in the Sun
thus logically being only fit to live
underground like grovelling goblins that
was actually Ben's justification for
putting me in the broom closet since
you're only fit to broadcast like a
groveling Goblin maybe well maybe Sarah
Jang is onto something here another
tweet hashtag cancel white people okay
that's it actually well Ben was using
that justification to get rid of this
show I don't know maybe maybe there's
really something to her media strategy
she goes quote
oh man it's kind of sick how much joy I
get out of being cruel to old white men
yeah I think that is sick she goes on I
dare you to play go to Wikipedia and
play things white people can definitely
take credit for it's really hard is it
well alright well we'll try that later a
next one quote white men are BS okay
next one quote @ rep dan mode white
people have stopped breeding you'll all
go extinct soon this was my plan all
along I guess that is just statistically
true because whites don't don't have a
lot of kids so alright maybe one of
those is almost defensible she just use
all of these that's this is just a
handful this isn't even all of them uh
the really incredible thing so we've
seen some this concerted effort to for
some people to just attack their
character go back find some joke they
made ten years ago and try to get them
for it this is not that this woman is
being hired for her opinions she's being
hired for her writing for the writing
that she's put out publicly and in the
very recent past these are the opinions
that she writes down that she thinks are
are worthy of publication and a being
put out for the public and they're
horrific I mean they're really really
wicked I dare you to read all of those
tweets and just replace white with black
just go through and read them now I know
some lefties are gonna object to this
they say oh stop it Michael there's no
such thing as reverse racism which is
true there's no such thing as reverse
racism
there's just racism it's that's all just
racism but one thing the lefties on
campus say is because they break
everybody down into these racial
categories and sex categories and all of
this and they say no no no racism is
when you're when you are mean to a
certain race you preach you judge a
certain race categorically and you have
power and privilege so you know they
always rank them they say okay Native
Americans have this this amount of
privilege and Mexicans have this amount
of privilege black people have this
amount of privilege whatever but the
irony of this is that Sarah Jong this
woman who was just hired by the New York
Times checks every privilege box right
if you're going to use the logic of the
left she is she's Asian in America and
statistically that that puts you at an
advantage right because Asians in
America categorically do better on an
academic standing in universities that's
actually why there's discrimination
against Asians and universities is
because they they do so well this is
what this Harvard lawsuit is about now
Harvard was discriminating in part
against white people but even more so
against Asian students because they
didn't want to fill up the whole class
with Asians many of whom were qualified
to go to Harvard how about where else
did she go she went to Harvard Law
School let's go it doesn't probably a
pretty good privilege checkmark she's
written for the atlantic she's written
for motherboard she's written for
Washington Post she's written for New
York Times Magazine if you're going to
use the logic of the left the privilege
logic it does not get more privileged
then this girl then this woman and she
is saying these horrific Allah racist
statements so what does the New York
Times say when this all comes to light
first of all obviously they knew about
these tweets they're not that stupid at
the New York Times I don't think they've
seen what she's been writing for the
past few years and what do they do they
hire her anyway and then they defend her
they sent out a statement about this
they said look she was the she's a
victim she's really a victim hey this is
always what they do whenever you find
somebody some leftist bully and you call
them out for being bullies they play the
victim so that they said Oh Sarah John
was being harassed by people for her
gender and her race and her this and for
that and blah blah blah blah blah and so
she responded and it wasn't good it
wasn't nice but you know that's if she's
the victim here no she's not she's a
vicious racist she said horrible and
indefensible things and I don't want to
ruin her life for that she can still go
get another job but she should not have
a job spouting these awful opinions the
one job she is now prevented from having
is offering her opinions in a mainstream
publication so this offers a couple
directions one the New York Times can
fire her if they want to remain a
mainstream not terribly radical
organization or by keeping her on staff
by saying no Sarah Jang is part of the
editorial board they are saying we are
radical we are radical we are racist we
defend all of these things that's who we
are now that's who we are and I think
most of us have known that the New York
Times has been this way for a long time
so it's not surprising at all but but I
guess now they're just forced to be
honest this is a really incredible
aspect of the Trump era in politics in
culture and politics people are being
more honest you know for years how long
have we said the Democrats are
socialists they're functionally
socialists they're embracing socialism
and they said no we're not I remember I
was I was advising a campaign in 2010
and there was a rumor going around that
our opponent the incumbent in the race
was a member of the Democratic
socialists of America just a rumor
someone sent it in we researched this
like crazy because that would have
killed his whole campaign it would have
killed it that would have been the end
of it right there he came out strongly
against me so I've never been part of
the Democratic Socialist no way no how
don't you dare say that now they're
being honest okay that candidate did
advocate socialist policies now they're
being honest about it they say yeah
we're socialists you got it you got me
yeah yeah we at the New York Times this
girl Sarah Jong yeah I hate white people
I don't like white people I don't I want
them to go extinct they don't like them
but at least she's being honest she's
not harboring her biases and her
prejudices and being deceitful about it
she's putting it out there in the open
the New York Times is saying yeah this
this is the kind of stuff we are these
are the people we hire these are the
opinions that we put out there there
okay that's fine we've known that for
years that they've been subversive and
awful and just a radical left rag now
they're being honest about it and even
voxcom voxcom is being pretty honest
out about their socialism so there was a
writer at voxcom megan day she writes in
this piece quote i'm a staff writer at
the socialist magazine Jacobin and a
member of the democratic socialists of
america and here's the truth in the long
run democratic socialists want to end
capitalism and we want to do that by
pursuing a reform agenda today in an
effort to revive a politics focused on
class hierarchy and inequality in the
united states the eventual goal is to
transform the world to promote
everyone's needs rather than to produce
massive profits for a handful of
citizens that last part is not how it's
gonna play out but she's being honest
and I really appreciate that you can you
can knock her for holding just a
pernicious and awful ideology but you
can't knock her for being deceitful at
least she's putting those ideas out
there that's really what they're saying
yeah we know no democratic socialists
were not just regular old liberals we're
not even regular old American lefties we
want to undo capitalism we want to
fundamentally transform America
I'll give her credit for that because
that is going to make this election
honest you've got 42 candidates right
now running state local federal in the
United States with the official
endorsement of the Democratic socialists
of America they're being honest they're
saying these are the ideas a real battle
between markets between economic freedom
and between socialism a rudy giuliani to
the excellent mayor of New York and also
now the lawyer for the president he is
saying that this investigation the
Muller investigation is all about
impeachment and therefore the midterm
elections are about impeachment Alan
Dershowitz came on the show the other
day he said the Democrats won't be able
to impeach Trump because they don't they
can't accuse him of a real crime there's
no evidence of a crime but the Democrats
who are now running for office are
running on an impeached Trump ticket
they think that impeachment is simply a
political matter it's not a legal matter
and they're gonna run for that and those
are the stakes I really like it between
between Megan day at voxcom
and Reid Giuliani they're saying look
these are the stakes in this election
impeachment or and socialism there are
two there's the political aspect of it
do you want to lose Trump do you want to
impeach drum
pretty want Trump to keep remaining in
office and keep making America great
again and then the political and the
philosophical side is does America want
to go down to the direction of socialism
down the direction of big government
telling you what to do having control
over your life being able to give you
anything you want and therefore being
able to take away everything that you
have do we want to go down that path or
do we want to go down the path that
we're currently on of deregulation of
economic freedom of strength abroad and
peace through strength do we want that
making America great again going back to
essential aspects of our American
tradition that have made this country
great that have made to this country
prosperous that have made this country
charitable do we want to go to that well
if we want to go to that then we need to
vote for Republicans because they're not
socialists and they're not going to
impeach Trump if you don't want that if
you want to become a socialist there's
an easy way to do it in this election
vote for the people who are honestly
telling you they're socialists vote for
the people who are honestly telling you
they want to impeach Trump you've got a
real choice you know Barry Goldwater at
the beginning of the modern conservative
movement Barry Goldwater said you know
you need a choice not an echo you don't
want there to be two parties that
basically resemble one another there
isn't much of a philosophical or
ideological distinction what you need is
a choice if you give Americans a choice
conservatives have a much better chance
of winning when we nominate squishy
people MIT Romney comes to mind or John
McCain comes to mind when you nominate
squishy Republicans not very
conservative Republicans they lose
because you're not giving people a
choice it's Democrat or Democrat light
but now there's there's some real
honesty here Barack Obama ran as a
moderate he wasn't a moderate guy he's a
radical guy he painted the White House
in rainbow lights he is a radical guy he
wants to fundamentally transform America
but when he would say those things he
would always back off them he would
always try to explain them away
these guys today I think in part because
of the raucous enos of President Trump
are being honest for the first time in a
while that's a beautiful thing I've got
to get to the mailbag pretty soon but I
don't I don't want to lose that aspect
because the only people now who are
still being dishonest are the mainstream
media they're the ones who are crying
for the Jim Acosta's who say wah wah wah
what stopped doing this you know
stop inciting violence the violence is
against Trump supporters it's not Trump
supporters against the media the
violence is the left-wing the violent
left-wing against Trump supporters media
figures and elected officials and
activists there was a I mean there are
so many examples of this just one that I
read before before the show is there was
an angry Trump critic who allegedly
punched a homeowner in Boynton Beach
Florida for having a Trump flag in his
front yard
he punches this guy right in the face
and then he drags the homeowner thirty
feet while driving away that is real
violence and that's not people saying
mean things to Jim Acosta and some
people heckling him while he's doing his
stupid report for CNN that is actual
violence and it's also not just the
crazies because even if there were some
crazy Trump supporters at these rallies
who were making threats to Jim Acosta
you might say well those are just the
crazies and we should deal with them but
they're just the the wackos the you know
they don't represent anything but for
the left the people calling for violence
or elected officials they're Maxine
Waters Cory Booker saying that if you
support judge Cavanaugh you support the
most stayed constitutional aspects of
this administration you are evil you are
complicit in evil it's all on that when
the when the Democrats are when the Left
accuse you of something they are
projecting this is almost always true
they're projecting they call you a
racist they're projecting their own
racism just read Sarah giong just read
who the New York Times is hiring to be
on their editorial board when they're
yelling you to tone down the rhetoric
listen to their rhetoric well listen
when they say stop being so hostile
notice that their face is red
they've got veins popping out of their
neck they've got steam coming out of
their is they say stop being so hostile
so what are your time I'm just trying to
sit my cofee over here I'm not what
would make you think that I'm being
hostile they are projecting all of that
and when they say don't get violent so
you're the one who's dragging the guy 30
feet in your car you Lefty it's not the
Trump supporters Trump supporters have
jobs well everybody in America has jobs
now cuz we have record low joblessness
things are going very well and we have
an honest election and we've got we're
getting conflicting reports in a lot of
reports of
esteemed analysts are saying the
Democrats are poised to take the house
they very well might take the house
historically speaking they probably
should take the house and we could
expect that a president Trump's approval
rating his amidst all of this amidst all
the constant harping 92% negative media
coverage of Donald Trump harping on
issues nobody cares about amidst all of
this Russia Muller collusion evil amidst
all that president Trump's approval
ratings at 50% record highs much higher
than Barack Obama's at this time in his
presidency five points higher that is
really big that's really big news and I
hope it bodes well for the future the
one thing we need to know is that
Republicans have stakes in this election
it's an honest election it will
determine the ideological future of the
country for in in to some degree for
some period and everything is on the
table
impeachment just socialism the future of
our country so you got to get out there
and vote because a lot of times we think
well our guys in office we don't need to
get out there you really do this is an
honest election history is gonna look
back on this election and say wow that
they were really being pretty honest
about what they wanted and it would be a
real shame if we lose it okay I gotta
get to the mailbag if you are on daily
wire calm thank you very much you helped
keep the lights on you keep Kofi Fay in
my cup you keep Jim Acosta's crocodile
tears pouring out and him cry me a river
that I can lap in and bathe in and drink
so if you're not there if you're on
Facebook or YouTube go over to Daley
wire calm you will pay 10 bucks a month
or $100 for an annual membership what do
you get you get me you get the under
Clavin show you get them in Shapiro show
you ask questions in a mailbag you test
questions in the conversation that's
coming up too and then you get you get a
life raft that's what you get you get a
life raft emits this deluge of Jim
Acosta tears don't miss the vintage the
Jim Acosta vintage is a really beautiful
one it's it's the Jim Acosta Will
Ferrell vintage of leftist years go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back with
the mailbag
all right let's get into it I always run
so late in the mailbag that today let's
try to burn through it let's let's try
to see if we get some more questions
than first one from Evan dear Great
distributor of cough fa and drinker of
leftist ears can you explain what
separation of church and state means for
Americans I find it hard to explain that
this separation doesn't and shouldn't
mean that government workers and elected
officials cannot be religious or
influenced by their religion but I am
being told my leftist - uncle by my
leftist uncle that people should keep
their religion between them and God I
find this absurd what was the original
intention of this concept for our
country has it gone too far thank you
Evan yes the the Establishment Clause
the First Amendment says we there won't
be an established religion in the United
States we can refer to this as the
separation of church and state though I
think that's a little misleading the
purpose of that separation is to protect
the church from the state it is not to
protect the state from the church as
John Adams said the United States is
built for a moral and religious people
it is unfit for the governance of
anybody else it is to protect the church
from the state you saw in other places
in other revolutions the French
Revolution is a good counter example of
this the separation of church and state
meant the destruction of the church they
knocked down churches they confiscated
church property they built temples to
reason they practically insisted on
atheism as a matter of course and as a
matter of law and look what that did you
the people who say keep your religion to
yourself don't you look you can be
religious I'm all for people being
religious but don't ever let that affect
anything that you do this is absurd st.
Francis of Assisi said preach the gospel
and if you must speak what is he saying
it means that if you've got the gospel
if you believe in Jesus if you're a
Christian this affects every aspect of
your behavior this affects everything
you do and it should affect everything
you do it should transform your soul you
know st. Paul wrote it there's no longer
I who lives but Christ who lives in me
well well st. Paul that's fine but don't
let him live publicly don't let us see
him living in you that's crazy this gets
to the other canard that people
throwout they say look we can't
legislate morality stop legislating
morality get your religion out of these
politics all political issues are
essentially religious issues because
they come down to first principles and
they come down to virtues and they come
down to values and they come down to
morals the question of raising taxes or
lowering taxes is a moral question the
question of health care certainly is one
and you hear religious language about it
all the time human rights what do human
rights come from human rights come from
natural rights natural rights come from
the natural law where's the natural law
come from from the natural log giver the
person who created nature the person who
created that natural law they all come
from the religious background you know a
st. Andrew Breitbart the patron saint of
modern conservatism
he said politics is downstream of
culture cultures downstream of the cult
its downstream of what we worship it
comes through all of that I talked about
this a little bit yesterday yeah for the
left politics is religion that's what
they worship it's why they use these
phrases erasure when you disagree with a
conservative they say okay you disagree
with me you don't like my opinion when
you disagree with a lefty they say
you're erasing my identity this is a
real phrase they use on campus and in
other circles and you're gonna hear it
become more mainstream you're erasing my
identity you're invalidating my identity
and in fact you are because that those
politics or their religious identity why
do we need to put caps on certain carbon
emissions why do we need certain fuel
standards in cars to save the planet
that's religion should we tell the left
to get their religion out of politics no
of course you can't do that because at
all it's all downstream of religion and
there it's a really shallow
understanding of religion and
philosophical thought and the and the
religiosity that built the West to say
we need to full we need to separate
church and state you can't do it this
form of government that we have comes
out of the very religious convictions
that built Western civilization so you
tell your lefty uncle not quite right
from Alex hello from Detroit this
Tuesday is the primary in Michigan I'm
torn who to vote for I'm a libertarian
conservative for the most part in none
of the Republican candidates aligned as
such in fact there was a large gap for
the leading Republican candidate who is
endorsed by Trump so I feel like my vote
wouldn't matter I am however tempted
vote on the Democratic ticket because
there's a woman running as a very
centrist Democrat against Medicare for
all
that's just socialism and wants to
reduce taxes on those in retirement the
second-place candidate on the Democratic
ticket is a very progressive individual
endorsed by Bernie and Alexandria Ocasio
cortes who will both be in Michigan
campaigning forums this Sunday okay so
you've got the you've got the Republican
candidate and then you've got the
moderate Democrat candidate and then
you've got the socialist candidate I'm
tempted to vote for the centrist dem
solely to do my part to ensure the
progressive does not win and
redistribute pudding to all what are
your thoughts I am all for strategic
voting I am all for strategic voting
some people say this is unprincipled
that isn't unprincipled at all your vote
is not your vote is not primarily a
religious action we're just talking
about religion and politics your vote is
not primarily about you feeling really
good about yourself your vote is not
primarily about you showing your virtue
to the world your vote is an instrument
for governance that's all it is it's a
way for you to participate in your
government and try to get the best
government that you can I don't know the
details of this race from what you've
told me though if the real threat here
is that the super left-wing progressive
candidate is going to win win the
primary win the general election and the
only way to stop her is by voting for
that centrist Democrat fine if that's
really the case I don't know the
particulars of this but if that's really
the case do that your your vote is not a
statement of your own virtue your vote
is a way to participate in governance
and try to get the best governance that
we can you should use it practically you
should use it realistically this is not
a moment to grandstand and tell
everybody how how wonderful and pure and
great you are now if the Republican can
win vote for the Republican absolutely
but if this is really about somebody
who's going to be a socialist and try to
get rid of all of our freedom and
somebody who's going to stem that tide a
little bit until we can get a Republican
in office do that do that absolutely
it's about the freedom it's about
preserving liberty it's about preserving
the country do what will work and and
don't worry about seeming super duper
purrr to all of your other friends
from Matthew how much time we have a
little bit more time from Matthew hey
Michael do you like the Latin Mass or
the Novus Ordo what do you think I'll
give you one guess I want I like I want
an Aramaic mass I wanted to go real
traditional I do I really like the Latin
Mass I don't relatively care for the the
Novus Ordo or the new liturgy that
you've had after 1965 with all of the
acoustic guitars and eagles wings and
you know it gets really frustrating why
is that though some people that some
people ask me about that they say why
why do you want the priests speaking in
a language that we don't really
understand and facing away from you it's
be it's about the purpose of the mass
what is the mass is the mass there to
entertain you whereas the mass there so
that you led by the priest can worship
God together what is it what is it about
being in communion with God or being
entertained and obviously it's about
communing with God that's why the priest
will face at orientem so that he's
leading you and you're all looking
together toward God rather than him
getting up there and doing a little
soft-shoe
and telling jokes for people and during
the homily he comes down he says hey
guys hey so listen here's the thing no
no here's the thing no hey guys one
should treat this seriously especially
in the in the Catholic Mass you've
you've got the real presence of Christ
right in front of you you've got got God
right before you on the altar don't
behave like you're at late-night comedy
and don't pretend it's open mic night at
the Comedy Cellar or something like that
it's not this is serious father Butler
who was on the show the other day he had
a great line about this I think I'm
quoting it almost perfectly where he
said that there are some priests who
like actors in a dying vaudeville show
tell jokes from the altar and those
priests should limit their repertoire to
the jokes that st. John told the Blessed
Mother while her son bled on the cross
that is my feeling on the traditional
liturgy and the novus ordo and I hope
what's interesting is that with the
newer more modernizing more acoustic
guitar masses the pews empty people are
not going to those but as beginning I
guess really with Pope Benedict
beginning with the reintroduction of
the popularity of Latin Mass those pews
are filling that's where people want to
go mostly because those guys have like
15 chi kids you know you look in the Pew
it's like boom boom boom boom boom boom
you know they are really filling in and
that that doesn't seem like a
coincidence to me that seems like
there's a real connection between that
faith and an exuberance in a pro-life
attitude and an embrace and embrace of
God and looking toward God so I highly
recommend you can go to a clayey dad org
and they will list some of the Latin
masses if there's one in your area even
if you're not Catholic even if you've
never been to one you should check it
out it going to serious liturgy is a is
a shocking experience and it fills you
with awe which is the beginning of
wisdom fear of the Lord is the beginning
of wisdom from Jacob I'm having trouble
with my faith and hoping you can offer
some insight I was in the Army for five
and a half years serving as an
infantryman my job was to hunt and kill
people I know that a lot of translations
of the Ten Commandments are wrong when
it reads thou shalt not kill when it
should be thou shalt not murder but in
war the line between murdering and
killing is blurred some of the times I
shot someone it was not clear if they
were enemies or just civilians at the
wrong place at the wrong time I often
wonder if I murdered one of these people
and if I did do I truly deserve to live
and seriously doubt I deserve to go to
heaven even though I try to live my life
according to the Bible I've attempted
suicide twice since I left the Army and
I'm often depressed I do go see a
counselor when I can get an appointment
at the VA and take antidepressants but I
can't seem to shake the guilt that I may
have murdered innocent people I guess my
question is does God give leeway to
soldiers for what we do in war Thank You
Jacob
the answer is yes yes he does I'm very
sorry to hear that you went through that
thank you for your service thanks for
protecting our freedom and our country
and I'm sorry that your your having
these psychological afflictions
afterward in these feelings of guilt yes
God does give Lee ways to soldiers and
times of just war absolutely to quote
General Patton I don't need to tell you
this but I believe it was Patton who
said war is a bloody killing business
it's a really awful thing war is a
terrible evil thing and it will never be
eradicated so long as human hearts are
beating because
that is the fact of life that is the
that is the worst most extreme extension
of politics and it is a defining feature
of civilization there is war
so in war you can either choose to fight
and protect your country and protect
your freedom and protect your family or
you can lay down arms and let the cruel
rape the face of the earth and
fortunately we don't do that in the
United States we don't do the latter we
defend our freedom and we do it because
people like you are willing to do that
and in times of war there is collateral
damage there are blurry situations it's
unclear sometimes if someone's a bad guy
or if someone's in the wrong place at
the wrong time that it is not going to
damn you to hell for that that does not
happen and on that point I should also
like to point out st. Paul was a
murderer st. Paul wasn't participating
in a just war st. Paul was a murderer
who killed Christians and persecuted
them and he is the Apostle he's the is
the great apostle who spread
Christianity
I'm I can't begin to imagine that the
psychological difficulty that that comes
with I'm not trying to make light of
that but you asked me a question so that
I can give you an outside perspective so
I can give you a little bit more
distance and a little bit of a more
objective perspective here of course God
gives leeway for that it's a wonderful
thing to defend your country defending
your country involves doing things that
hurt and that might be wrong and that
have make mistakes because war is an
evil evil thing but you did the right
thing defending your country and you're
not going to go to hell for doing the
right thing I hope that helps from Noah
what's crack-a-lackin' my homie I bet
this is gonna be a lighter question than
the last one what's crack-a-lackin' my
homie Michael ninety-nine I haven't yet
read but was given a copy of Howard
Zinn's book of people's history of the
United States by my more liberal parents
obviously you're not a fan but I've
heard relatively conservative history
podcaster Dan Karlin described it as
having been intended to provide a
counterbalance to a hyper patriotic
narrative that was found in other
textbooks of the time he also expressed
a belief that it is a college level
textbook in terms of what it expects
from its readers as well as that it
should be read in conjunction with the
work that was intended to counter and
consider with a heavy dose of critical
thinking to provide a complete picture
of history
how do you feel about the validity of
this position if it were used strictly
in this fashion do you believe it should
be a useful part of an education about
American history thanks Noah no it's
just trash it's an absolute trash book
to use a line to use a word rather that
Ben uses to describe me mitch Daniels
described that book as execrable the
former governor of Indiana current
president of Purdue it is an execrable
book a truly execrable book it is awful
it it first of all I believe it was
voted by a number of historians to be
the worst history book or the second
worst history book of modern times it
just really awful but it's awful for a
few reasons one it distorts the truth it
it is a presents a very perverse
distortion of the truth of American
history but also what it does is it
instills in its readers a hatred of
their country and it also ideologically
instills in its readers an idea that
leaders don't matter that great men
don't matter that men who make the
individual decisions that guide history
they don't matter all that matters is
them the great unwashed masses who have
been oppressed and put upon it is an
ideological polemical work of trash if
you want to read it that's why I read
plenty of trash and it's sort of
interesting to read it as an
intellectual exercise to realize just
how viciously anti-american the Left can
be but it should not be considered part
of a history education it is it is not a
serious history book it's a left-wing
ideological polemic and it's trash and
it shouldn't be on a curriculum because
when I when I've seen it assigned in
classes and I've seen that firsthand or
excerpts of an aside from classes it's
not there to provide a counterbalance
it's there for the meat they tell you oh
yes this was to provide a counterbalance
but you're not really exposed to those
primary and more serious and classical
texts you just read this and you say
this is the counterbalance no forget it
it is trash do we have more time we got
time for like one or two more from Dale
dear mr. Knowles hey man I'm for
abortions yep I'm an evil left-wing
crazy who's like who likes killing the
unborn not really but I wish I could get
on the right-to-life train here is my
problem in a nutshell without abortions
unwanted children will be born to women
who hated the idea
having a child so much that they're
willing to remove the fetus from their
body so my question is who will take
care of the unwanted the children being
born from young girls make that children
themselves you know girls 14 15 or 16
years old who thought that the young
handsome man was going to take her away
but only left them pregnant
what place will they end up at because
adoptions will at best take in 10%
reasonable guests who will raise the
rest by the way your reasonable guess is
you pluck that out of thin air
isn't that who does not come from
anywhere a single moms were state-run
orphanages who will pay for all care and
who will love the children Dale it keeps
going on but this is too long no oh so
your your your beginning with all of the
objections that one would have to these
babies your beginning like three stages
down the line well but what if no one
wants them what if they're not raised
right what if they're not loved that
would all be terrible would that be
worse than murdering them no nobody
honestly believes that it would be worse
than murdering them the question you
have to ask yourself is is this a human
yes it's a human it's not a duck it's
not a dog it's not a dinosaur it's a
human is this an individual or is this
just a part of the mother it's an
individual it has individual DNA it
grows individually it grows separately
from the mother it's its own it has its
own organs it's not a part of the mother
and is it alive yes it's alive it's
growing it's consuming nutrients it it
will be its own person and left
unimpeded it will grow to a very ripe
old age unless something terrible
happens or unless somebody murders it
that's it so do you have the right to
kill it no should you kill it no is it
perverse to have a mother kill her child
yes mother Teresa said that's the
greatest source of evil in the world and
I'm likely to agree with that now if you
say well the child will be the mother
considered abortion and so therefore
she's she'll be a terrible mother first
of all that's not necessarily true if
you're a 14 or 15 year old girl and
you're scared because you're pregnant
and the thought crosses your mind that
doesn't mean you can't be a good mother
people have fears all the time people
think perverse things all the time
people have temptations to evil all the
time
that doesn't mean you can't do good
that's ridiculous as for adoption there
are a lot of people trying to adopt
babies in the United States and to adopt
American babies in the United States I
don't think the options are kill it or
leave it on the doorstep of the fire
department or something that is not the
case but the question you're so far down
the line ask yourself the question would
you kill that person would you kill that
little baby no should you kill a little
baby know which of these arguments could
you not use to take out whole other
populations elderly populations to use
the example that one of the examples
that turned me pro-life to kill ethnic
minority young man 18 to 24 and in the
in urban areas which of these arguments
well they'll create problems for society
well it's hard for the mother that look
life involves suffering is it worth
killing that kid absolutely not
unfortunately we got to go there we got
we got even more questions but sad we'll
get to next time okay very good to see
everybody make sure we got a second
season of another Kingdom coming up and
you know another Kingdom is the last
time I'm ever gonna work in Hollywood
the only people who hire me anymore or
are Dennis Prager for his movie
Andrew Clavin for another Kingdom and
Ted Cruz for his commercials so you know
go out there make sure you check it out
binge and we've got an episode by the
way coming out tomorrow there's just a
little treat I know you're also we've
got an because I was gone in DC for
Wednesday we've got another episode
tomorrow so listen to another Kingdom
and then in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you